le préfet de l'oise fermer les marchés
en plein air mais il laisse ouvert les
grandes surfaces et les îles les
hypermarchés ou dit qu'après tout le
petit détaillant le petit maraîcher à
une force de capacité de se plaindre
bien moindre que anne hypermarchés par
exemple sont que ce sont je le ferme et
si on est là et l'autre pas si on
regarde la communication gouvernementale
je trouve qu'elle est relativement bien
maîtrisé puisqu'il est important la
communication de que des experts soient
crédibles donc là je pense qu'ils
laissent la place comme l'a dit le
général de la santé les des instructions
pour que nous chaque jeu directeur des
communications du bit est le chef de
service ne parle pas directement au
public mais la variation soit transmise
est gérée à l'échelle collective les
consignes sont relativement claires il
ya quand même eu des progrès du côté de
la mévente inouïe certinomis avait
raison en plein air on a moins de
risques selon tami n'est que dans un
milieu confiné je suis absolument
aberrant c'est de fermer les marchés
mais alors qu'on sait très bien que ça
va vraiment posé des problèmes à 10
petits détaillants alors cela dit si
c'est grave il faut le faire mais quand
même
mais quand même maman on laisse ouvert
les grandes surfaces ça paraît dingue
est ce que le y aurait pas une logique
économique la tête à coup franc
[Musique]